last week on kill Tony something bizarre
happened Tony hinchcliff found out 15
minutes after the show was already
underway that normal regular David Lucas
was not going to make it the production
team had to scramble but luckily there
was already a local Legend in attendance
who was watching the show on mushrooms
Austin's own Ron White I my pants
on the golf course today
let me walk you through that
I got back from California had a stomach
virus but I promised I would play in a
chariot event I showed up for it and I
felt like that if I farted for like 15
minutes I would be about good pressure
wise the full clip is even better if you
didn't see it yet